Senku was still working until this midnight.
What is it?  The battle with Mr. Tsukasa
If you don't mind, can you tell
me what happened with Zasan?
I want
to pass on myths to children as a shrine maiden.
[Music] In an
instant, the front team was petrified.
Let me leave it to you
[music]
I bought it for fantasy with science
t It's beyond that moon
ni
Why did the petrification melt away?
The first thing to do is Tsukasa,
she's too muscular and laughable
Yeah,
me
Super You guys won't be in danger again
From now on, I'll be the one to fight
[music]
Is Stone World 2
It's a chance to give humanity a chance, but I don't think so
Synchron
[music]
none With
the power of science, I'll help humanity without exception
[music]
That's why I decided to walk a different path with Tsukasa-san.  It's not a long
-winded story, it's just
started, there's
no battle between science and power, and it's a
good ending, and it's a volcanic powerhouse.
Could you please tell me the recipe for the petrified resurrection station that was being used
Resurrection is a mixture of admiration and alcohol
Can you swear here and now
if you abandon science then I will
not kill you and move on  That's
impossible, but
if we had met 3,700 years ago, we
might have become friends for the first time.
No matter what kind of resuscitation treatment you do in the world, it
's meaningless.Remember 1009.Ah
, there's a little petrification left on the neck
.
The sound of saying has disappeared ao I've
built up 9 heads
The 10th Useria I'll give 10 billion perfect marks to the two of you I
'm misunderstanding that it
's my place in the other world On the other hand I like Tsukasa's place anytime  I understand
this kind of advantageous
battle.The two of us, stage names, have infiltrated the Tsukasa Empire as spies
.
Speaking
of the kingdom of science,
where did you first meet
Kohaku?
Transforming the garbage-like power of a high school student into buying power
My name is Kohaku
What do you think?
My mother is going to create a ward country.
Starting with those who came from outside, I went up to the
bread packer daughter rar ah
ran
ni dare
n It won't be long for me I
'm hungry, right?
tan tan
yeah yeah yeah I should put that out re 1 rar [music] I could see it from the shore Oh I'm buying myself hired at Kurobe store
What are you doing at Hugh Sun Moon?
There's a guy who's doing scientific research with the intention of doing witchcraft. It's a
car. What's the rainbow bridge?
Let's start a scientific country together
And let's take care of Ruri's sick Buddha! It's a
school!
rj Booey
I've been trying to find out if there's anyone who wants something
The sand is a swindle that makes a name judgment
This scent
is haha ​​If you read Boo Boo Teri and assessment
Yuzuriha is doing fine. Daini-chan knows about the same physical strength, right?
1009 Choi
My job is to make sure that Senku-chan is dead.
I'm collecting stone statues of
humans Let's create a new world together
If the man named Senku is still alive
, I want you to find him
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
Shaving it all over and going through the salt
and tinctures
Why are you becoming Anpanman?
There's no darkness in this era
[Music]
Air It's electricity in
the Stone Age Hey, Tsukasa-chan  I'm going to flow as much as I can
Clean Paju
Haa So I can't compete with Marushin
[Music] With
sweat and tears
I created the totes lens for this time
I'm doing it
[music]
Free rides in the morning are empty dare
Hey, we've won the championship, so we're going to finish the sake sideways So let's
just go
It's the crystallization of wisdom, my
feet are learning,
and I believe in the sky before
[music]
I got it.
It's a new number
.
Activation
I told everyone I'd come back and let them know
me
car
kanjani It was a prize yeah yeah yeah
While Senpu-san is turning this village into a science kingdom
Susa-chan, I'm going to be tempering and increasing my stomach.
I wonder if I
'll end up using it to put up a little bit of gunpowder.
You said that you completed freedom with the power of more than 10 billion
w
Already had power regardless of brothers and sisters You were
alive, 1009-kun is
sure to defeat 2009 with all possible measures.
A fun scientific invention will come out.In
modern warfare, the one who wins will win.When mankind is the
strongest in 2 million years, it's
okay to help in
this stone world.
Then we'll make a two-act extra-fine wire
No, we
can make a waterwheel Ah, the era of human power is over  So,
chain 9, since the Lord came, the spell has become an
order of magnitude more difficult,
and it's fun for the
child who came.
Well then 4 ni
Maybe today I
'll buy Poo 5. It's my
sister by chance
Hey, what is Duke Level?
[Music]
[Applause] The most
powerful weapon in modern warfare
, the explosion of mobile phones
[Music] It
's almost time
for the decisive battle
against Senku.  Stand
up and build up a clean synth porridge
[music]
me
me My
brother's head
Hey, it was in the
kite  It's a reconnaissance to see if there's any movement in the black.
is 4  About
why are you sleeping under the laboratory
bench?  But ah, you say something like a scientific surprise item
What is modern?
Don't fall in love I hear the roar and it's impossible for the monitor to check it
Where is that movement that makes
me cry me
[music]
gymnastics
There's no way I'm going to kill you in the darkness of this zone
I'm in the cherry tree
I'm in a hurry because I'm trying to make you run out of breath by answering on purpose I'm in a
hurry The flames that can't be
pulled
apart Even at 3 o'clock the gap won't shrink It's
fast
I wonder if you're the
eyeball  You can take a close look at
the surprise of science item level 2 It's a
flash ball
dee
ana ah ah ah
ah You can do it with the power to escape by force
d
This woman's taijutsu eh
Chrome and magma aren't just for Nanoki-san, who has a full line-up of
villagers.  The
movement of the 2nd-ranked cellphones reflected in the movement of the second-ranked run from the important science department.
It's only a matter of time until it's discovered, so
we have no choice but to
catch it before that.  So, Prost, there's a light mark on the spot.
Ah, I chose the
time.